making notes bookmarking ideas in your
textbook
leaving reminders for your best friend
on a note
writing important calendar events on
your study table
what is the most common and attractive
way to do these things
take a bright and colorful sticky note
and post it
right but why use a post-it note when
you have a simple paper
post-its have a sticky glue that helps
the piece of paper to stay put
so that you don't miss the important
stuff
plus you can always make color-coded
notes
with bright and playful colors
post-its have been the most remarkable
invention in the history of office
and school stationery from reminders to
bookmarks
and from planning workflows and
processes
post-its come in handy everywhere
but do you know how this simple but
awesome invention was born
[Music]
no no problem let's meet arthur frye
the man who invented the concept of
post-it
arthur frye was a singer at the night
choir of a minnesota church
he always used paper bits to remember
the important chords for his
choir performance but these paper pieces
would fall off before his performances
at the church
one day even without looking for it
arthur found the solution to this
problem
he was attending a seminar by spencer
silver a scientist
at 3m silver had created a unique
low-tech adhesive this invention of
silver
was an accident he was originally trying
to create
adhesives for aerospace to hold strong
objects together
but he failed and thus ended up with a
low-tech glue
although this glue was weak it was
strong enough to cling onto objects to
allow a temporary bond
one could even reuse it multiple times
when arthur found out that silver was
still searching for a marketable use
for his accidental invention he got an
amazing idea he requested silva for a
sample of this adhesive
to try it on the paper bits for his
church choir notebook
and voila it worked really well
the paper bits stayed put in the book
without falling off
at first it was church choir notebooks
later it was arthur's office documents
the glue was working silver's brand new
adhesive
could be coated on paper this paper
could hold itself on any surface
without damaging it the idea was taken
to 3m
who marketed to the world all they
needed was a name
for this unique product they called it
present peel but the name did not stick
well with the users
hence the company renamed it as postage
they gave free samples to every office
in boys idaho
and astoundingly ninety percent of all
the officers
placed an order for the post-its
moreover
the posted totes would sell themselves
how well if a user marked his document
with
post-it and shared it with other users
they would find the notes amusing yet
very helpful in organizing
hence they would place an order for
their own post-hit
now have you ever wondered why post-it
notes are mainly
yellow in color well there is a fun fact
behind this
when the makers were producing the first
batch they found
low-cost yellow paper in abundance in a
nearby factory
hence they created the first batch of
post-it with this
yellow paper which later became their
identity
and they stuck with it 3m
now produces over 50 billion of these
yellow sticky notes
every year that's a huge number isn't it
besides this frey silver duo's
innovation
has given birth to many more such
inventions
for example big sticky pads are a
notepad version of post-it
super sticky notes which have a stronger
glue that sticks better to vertical
and non-smooth surfaces so did you
notice
how a super failed product elsewhere
gave birth to an amazingly powerful
idea and ultimately led to a
revolutionary product
can you think of any such product or
idea which has
a super use in some other way if yes
then you are on a similar journey as mr
arthur fries
now what do we learned from this posted
story
yes we have to learn from failures and
make them work
write this on a post-it and stick it in
your mind
but permanently are there other
interesting things you know about
post-it do tell us in the comment
section below
and don't forget to visit the empower
website to learn more about
entrepreneurship happy learning